sep tember brought the first wave of big
releases to outdoor steps starting with
the long-awaited and controversial Metal
Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain hideo
kojima supposed swan song with konami
takes the series into open-world
territory for the first time and it
serves as the missing piece in a saga
that began almost 30 years ago then you
found freedom on the battlefield was a
huge success paving the way for emergent
gameplay that tied the world together
and kept you on your toes lucky for
Konami the phantom pain wasn't its only
great game last month as they also
released pro evolution soccer 2016 we
praised the game for its physics engine
and artificial intelligence calling PES
2016 the best game in the series since
the playstation 2 era how's 2016 is
measured against EA sports as of 3 4
2016 which we lauded for its new passing
mechanics and other welcome tweaks that
added strategic depth to the game's
great foundations introducing fresh
skills for seasoned players to master
just ahead of Halloween amnesia
developer frictional games Unleashed
soma a chilling and thought-provoking
horror game where shrieking spies haunt
you in a dreadful and murky world soma
provokes your fear of the unknown puts
you in unsettling confrontations with
puzzling creatures and delivers a
meaningful narrative on the opposite end
of the spectrum nintendo released the
endearing and versatile Super Mario
maker it's a level creation tool that
puts you in control of elements from
Fall Classic Mario Brothers games and
lets you easily share your creations
with other players from around the world
the results so far have been impressive
and Super Mario maker is a rewarding
experience that's drawn people's
attention back to the way you ultimately
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain was
out near unanimous choice for
September's game of the month Metal Gear
Solid can be a divisive series due to
its complex plot but the phantom pain
captivated audiences both new and old
alike it tells an unbelievable story
that intertwines real world of
from the 1980s with loads of melodrama
fantastical characters and an offbeat
sense of humor you slip into the boots
of a super soldier with a tragic
backstory and an army at his command who
must face impossible odds while sneaking
behind enemy lines the phantom pain has
a massive world that's been crafted with
an incredible attention to detail which
is reflected in the interplay of
numerous mechanics the artificial
intelligence and the flexibility of the
emergent gameplay moments that await you
at every turn the phantom pain is the
Metal Gear series is missing link and
while not everyone is pleased by the way
Kajima tied things together he certainly
managed to do what he does best deliver
a story that subverts expectations
redefining the truth and your
understanding of the series at large we
gave the phantom pain a 10 in our review
not because it's a perfect game but
because it offers an essential
experience that we think everyone should
try